Zoe what was your advice be to other
actresses over 40 who their creative
their vibrant they want to still go on
they don't want to hide their head under
the covers but at the same time they
know the realities they know all the
digs that people throw their way well um
I think it's I mean I think it's pretty
obvious what it is that being an actor
is to me it would have been a horribly
frustrating job because you have to wait
you have to wait for someone to accept
you if to wait you have to put all your
faith and all your whatever into someone
else's decision and that would drive me
bananas so I see a lot of really great
really talented actresses writing parts
with themselves now or co-writing parts
or directing things and moving into
production on the other side to make
sure that they have the parts that they
want and it's really really really
interesting I just reading a story in
The New York Times about Amanda Peet it
was exactly the same thing she turned 40
years old she could she had a great
career that kind of petered out into
this place where she was kind of lost in
this age group and she wrote a play for
herself that ended up she ended up
giving the part away to Sarah Jessica
Parker because she thought she was a
better I'm chin think she was a better
fit but she thought she was great and
she thought oh my god I can have this
woman and she can portray this and I can
be the writer so she stepped back and
she let herself you know be a different
part but be a creative and I think that
happens with you know in movies and you
see a lot more female directors now and
I think you know I think and I think
directors just need to take a little
more care about females you know whether
they're a woman director or mad director
you know so you even said I think
something similar for female filmmakers
that if they kind of have a quirky niche
or style to them they're accepted or
else they can go into what what is it
called the girl ghetto which is all of
the documentary filmmakers that are
female but in terms of being a narrative
filmmaker it's a little you said there's
there's its own sort of stereotypes with
that as well oh yeah well I mean you
know
we as women we're constantly men are
constantly hoping that we're going to
make chick flicks and you know so women
will go men don't have to go but you can
still make the right amount of money
that you can because you made a chick
flick and and that's fine I've my love
of chick flick but i also love a serious
movie and i don't think that there's a i
mean i don't think there's enough dramas
actually directed by women you know
thank God for a mere and I air who
decides to make you know real serious
narrative movies but if you think about
it we're all kind of regulated into this
like we're a woman we're working and
then we're gonna find love and we're
going to lose it but we're gonna get it
back and then we're gonna realize that
we're probably not really good about
working we should rather be just happy
in love you know and that's you know a
little offensive but we laugh but
there's some truth to it yeah I mean
it's called irony
you